why are we being sneaky I thought you
said we have permission we do I just
don't want anybody knowing about a
platinum smart last week I bragged about
having a Nutter Butter and some rat
stole it right out of my lunch bag
well sure wasn't me now we'll just wait
for the concrete dust is resolved and
the led to melt that's exactly right
no no I listen and you understand that I
work in sales I don't need to know what
I'm talking about to make it sound good
don't you think it would make you better
at your job if you understood the
products you were selling no people
don't want to hear fat I do normal
people don't want to hear facts I'm
normal are you
no I'm special
you're supposed to be doing that
something's wrong maybe we didn't sit
down all the work where I think it's
burning okay okay calm down
I lanolin
what were you thinking well I don't want
to hear excuses you gotta burn the
school down what do you have to say for
yourselves but you didn't want to hear
my excuses oh no we didn't break into
the classrooms Georgie had permission
from the teacher that's not important
right now
so you think a teacher said it was okay
for a ten-year-old and an idiot to use a
2000 degree oven unsupervised
you feel
who you also stole my never butter yeah
are you still interested in getting rich
quick no I want to do it slow like a
chomp oh never mind
tell me Sheldon it occurred to me that a
good way to generate a positive cash
flow would be to cure a popular songs to
make them available in a digital form
possibly in a small device that could
also be used as a phone or even a camera
right a phone camera music machine get
out of here
[Music]